i'm hamish linklater and i play father
paul i'm samantha's loyan and i play
beverly keane hi i'm kate siegel and i
play aaron green i'm zach gilford and i
play riley flynn my name is annabeth
gish and i play dr sarah gunning hi i'm
kristen lehmann and i play annie flynn
and today we're here with buzzfeed to
answer burning questions
so just be aware there are spoilers for
the show so if you don't want spoilers
stop watching now
when i was cast i knew basically nothing
i had two scenes that were both in the
first episode and besides that all i
knew was mike's work i won the job i was
really excited and then i got to read
the scripts and i was like holy
like this is really good i knew
everything about my character and my arc
because i had read the scripts unlike
sam sloyan who just like made up her
role
i knew quite a bit and uh but you never
really know even when mike tells you
where something's going until you read
how he makes it happen you really don't
know you're like oh that is what you
meant going in i only had one audition
scene when i got it i still knew very
little until i started receiving all the
scripts at the same time then i knew
everything but that was well before we
began we knew immediately what we were
creating which i personally find way
more beneficial as an actor mike had
sent me he could text me about a role in
the show i
said i was definitely interested in
probably in and then he sent me a few
episodes and i was hooked
well when the book midnight mass was in
a hush it was in novel form mike hadn't
written it as a film which is what
became next and then a series so it was
mike flanagan's great unfinished novel
so i always thought it was going to be a
book and i thought the only life it
would ever have on screen was hush here
we are
i think it was really really lucky zach
and i were together for the first two
weeks of shooting like we did all of the
aaron and ryan stuff at the beginning
and we would talk about monologue day
monologue day is coming i mean zach had
it plastered to his wall like that meme
of the person with the red like it's
like freaking zodiac in there trying to
put together all of these thoughts and
then on the day we just sat down and
kind of looked at each other and the
thing about zach gilford is he's this
incredibly grounded and generous and
self-deprecating person and i would look
at him and he would just be waiting for
me and like he was like we're going to
go on this journey together for all of
the shots we take at each other offset
like we're going to be gentle and kind
with each other and i don't think i
could have done it with any other human
being but zach because it's kind of an
embarrassing thing what we do
like to play make-believe on that level
and to truly let yourself pretend that
you're somebody else saying these things
she just was so present and giving and
it feels like when you're talking to her
she's listening a lot of times in
different projects if you're not on
camera a lot of people give it 50 or 70
or 80 percent kate you know always even
if the camera like she was like
literally sitting on the dolly with the
camera she was still doing the one tier
i love the one tier she's not even on
camera i don't even know how to do the
one here and she's doing it off camera
i think playing evil comes natural to
say i'm trying to tear people down i'm
more of a builder upper it's kind of
worse if you think about it because you
trust him you know what you get with me
who do you want the guy who pulls the
rug out from under you or the person who
comes running at you screaming i'm
whacking you with the rug and then rolls
you up in it and tosses you five miles
out i mean really i'm the less
villainous of the two
it was fun to be honest there's not a
lot of times in tv specifically but in
movies as well where you get to shoot
like a 10 minute or however long it is
seeing where it's just two people in
chairs talking to each other in this
instance who is this weird priest
telling me this craziness hamish is
amazing and like i can't imagine anyone
else in that role him and i were friends
before this project good friends i
didn't even know he had auditioned for
he was on the radar and literally when i
got off at the part they're like yeah
and and hamish link later is gonna be
the priest i was like hey what and as
soon as i heard that i was like that
genius like i can't imagine anyone else
in this role when he was coming in to do
a read which you know he doesn't do a
lot like he's an accomplished actor i'd
beg to be the reader like whether he
gets this part or not i want to see him
do it i dropped like a bunch of his cues
because the second he started talking i
was just like hey mitch is good at this
exactly just like just down the street i
was like oh
oh that's why they cast me to play this
part that works that works
before i tried anything we shot that it
happened right on the heels of her
saying farewell to her only living son
in the middle of this very real insane
circumstances the weight with which i
wanted to lean into your that moment and
really like milk it i also was like i
can't do that this has to be you know
what i mean none of that was faked like
the wind was ripping through everything
these embers were flying through the air
they had to position and remove and move
trucks so that we could just
try and make this happen before we had
to shut down for the night they actually
had to pull the plug so it was one of
those things where you know nature
conspired to help us and it was fabulous
and uh yeah i loved it
it didn't affect how i played riley just
because his arc was so there and made
sense so i just kind of played it as if
there were only five episodes and the
two that happen after i'm gone like
who's gonna watch those anyway the end
show over but we shot that scene it was
our second day of shooting to go in and
shoot your death scene your second day
of shooting for a seven episode show is
difficult and you don't know your scene
partner luckily she was kate and she was
there for me the one thing i do have to
say
is that
before we shot the coverage of me
screaming and that scream that lasts all
over all the credits mike and trevor
asked me if i wanted to see
the special effects shot that they were
shooting and so they bring in this like
wire dummy wearing zach's clothes
rigged up to like some strings and on
action they cut the strings and it just
collapses like pinocchio i was weeping
just like crying with laughter because
it is the funniest most insubstantial
death that i'm now and in reality it's
going to be this incredible what turned
out to be the special effect that was
like heartbreaking and all these things
and then they're like all right up on
the boat with you time to scream
oh you know that was actually pretty
great kate is uh one of my favorite
people in the entire world i love bev's
face as she gets taken you know there's
just the little like oh there she goes
you know like everybody watches her go
and then like she's being torn apart in
the background and life carries on
at the scene around the table where i
have a whole bunch of medical jargon
that i have to deliver it was a
tremendous i felt a lot of pressure to
deliver that with the right tone and
medical accuracy
all of your scenes but definitely the
scene where you say what's a little
crazy between president you've got
corrections
you're creepy mom a surprise favorite
scene is in the first episode that i
that we have together me and sam where
she asked me why i'm wearing the wrong
colored chawsable that was like one of
the few scenes that we like got the day
before or something like that yeah he's
so right the other scripts we had you
know which is delightful we had sat with
them for months and months good choice
hamish way to go me and bev in the
school closet sam and i were friends for
years and i crop dusted every single
time i left that room so she's just
standing there in my farts
it's true well you outed yourself that
was before i knew i had a gluten allergy
i just like inked thanked myself sorry
kate but anything i had with henry was
it's okay because i couldn't keep a
straight face and there's this one scene
where it's the whole family at the
dinner table he's like no uh-uh nope
it's like you're so ridiculous but i
really loved shooting the scene of him
and i on the boat and because it was
like there was plans of like we had this
huge crane on another boat blah blah
blah but we're on the water in the
middle of the ocean so the cranes like
like they can't get a shot and so
finally mike was like all right just get
rid of that we'll just have one camera
on the boat with someone holding it and
after we did it and this is what i
always feel like is the sign of a good
scene is when your crew comments on it
our focus puller when they yell cut goes
that was really cool and then our
cameraman goes it's like the awkward
conversation we all wish we could have
with our father made me just feel like
yeah we did a good job thanks so much
buzzfeed midnight mass is streaming now
on netflix check it out
you